oh
montréal un nouvel emblème le pont
samuel de champlain un géant de béton et
d'acier qui s'étire sur plus de trois
kilomètres
on a voulu donner à montréal qu'on
distinctifs une signature pour la ville
le nouvel ouvrage ne ressemble en rien à
son prédécesseur il est plus large plus
haut et courbet il est composé de trois
tabliers distincts plutôt que de
recourir trois jeux deux piliers
d'architectes a choisi de n'en mettre
que deux ils sont inclinés est surmonté
de chevêtres en forme de w
ses cheveux être fabriqués en espagne
ont donné du fil à retordre aux
constructeurs
ces pièces en forme de w sont uniques
elles sont très difficiles à fabriquer
mais c'était une exigence dictée par les
plans de l'architecte l'architecte le
danois paul rouve et jensen défend son
choix
dénicher la solution facile aurait été
d'avoir trois rangées de pilier mais on
se serait retrouvé avec une forêt de
béton dans l'eau ça aurait complètement
obstrué la vue comme ce l'était in fine
pioche les piliers inclinés était la
solution logique
en bonus montréal hérite d'un pont
unique et distinctif
la partie la plus spectaculaire c'est
celle qui surplombe la voie maritime
cette zone du fleuve est exclusivement
réservée à la circulation des navires
on ne peut pas y installer des piliers
pour soutenir les tabliers
il a fallu construire au-dessus du vide
sur le vieux pont champlain
c'est une structure en treillis qui
permettait d'enjamber la voie maritime
cette fois on abdé pour des haubans 60
câble blick relié au pilote principal
c'est tout simplement comme des cordes
qui viennent tenir le tablier de façon à
ce qu'on n'ait pas besoin de mettre deux
fils en dessous du tablier sur la
distance qui est au banik ça vous permet
avec cette espèce d'artifice de passer
au dessus du chenal sans avoir besoin
d'avoir deux piliers les haubans du pont
samuel de champlain sont parmi les plus
gros jamais installé à l'intérieur ils
sont composés de plus d'une centaine de
câbles d'acier qu'on appelle des
taureaux pourquoi ils sont très gros
c'est parce qu'on a deux nappes d'eau
vent pour soutenir trois tabliers hockey
la plupart des ponts ou vannes et au
monde il ya de nabeul 2 au vent donc
comme on dirait ici deux nappes d'eau
vente pour un tablier ici on est dans un
cas vraiment unique
à date où on est en train de soutenir
trois tabliers donc trois ponts vraiment
avec seulement deux nappes de au vent à
l'intérieur de chaque aube en trois
capteurs vont permettre de suivre
l'attention des taureaux
au besoin on pourra les revendre ou les
remplacer
leur durée de vie prévue est de 40 ans
c'est aux banques cédaient à ce que le
procès devrait quand même alors tout à
fait il a été demandé aux concepteurs de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse perdre 3 ou
vent simultanément consécutif à
n'importe quel endroit de la structure
d'accord donc c'est à dire que si on a
pour une raison accidentelle ou quoi que
ce soit jusqu'à 3 ou man qui viendrait à
lâcher ou à ne plus faire leur effet
ex compter la structure tiendrait quand
même deux bouts alors ça veut pas dire
que la structure serait nickel et qu'on
pourrait continuer à l'utiliser mais
elle serait il y aura pas d'effondrement
et elle sera réparable en plus de
soutenir d'énormes charges
les haubans vont devoir résister au vent
et au verglas en décembre 2012
les automobilistes qui traversaient le
pont portman près de vancouver ont reçu
des blocs de glace sur leur voiture en
pleine tempête de neige et verglas
les haubans du pont se sont mis à vibrer
des blocs de glace se sont détachés des
câbles les ingénieurs du pont samuel de
champlain ont travaillé en collaboration
avec les chercheurs du conseil national
de recherches du canada pour éviter que
ça se produise à montréal sur le nouveau
pompe la gaine qui recouvre les haubans
est équipé de minces nervures parallèle
des anneaux espacées de 30 cm ce relief
doit aider à diriger le flux du vent
pour réduire les vibrations les nervures
sont aussi censés réduire la taille des
blocs de glace qui pourraient se former
sur les haubans un coup dessus glace
suffira pour enlever ce qui est tombée
sur votre pare-brise
on est au dessus de la l'entretoise
inférieure du futur pont champlain le
pont samuel de champlain a été construit
dans l'urgence en moins quatre ans pour
remplacer son prédécesseur
arrivé à la fin de sa vie utile après
seulement 60 ans cette fois on a pris
des précautions pour assurer la
durabilité des ouvrages
les attentes sont énormes contrairement
à l'ancien pont champlain
la nouvelle structure est équipé d'un
système de drainage pour éviter qu'en
hiver les sels de déglaçage tacle béton
de chaque côté des trois corridors des
plus à capter les eaux et les diriger
vers des canalisations dissimulée à
l'intérieur des piliers
autre précaution toutes les armatures de
la dalle du tablier sont en acier
inoxydable résistant à la corrosion
nouveau pont sera aussi sous constante
surveillance grâce à un réseau de 400
capteurs électroniques